trump returns to the white house and
causes new controversy with his masking
habits trump tweets optimistically about
covet and the media lose their minds and
joe biden continues to skate toward the
presidency i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's how my listeners secure their
internet join them at expressvpn.com
ben well we will get to all the news in
just one moment first
wouldn't it be nice if you could just
save money on all of your
phone needs so here is the reality you
are paying far
too much far too much on your cell phone
bill if your cellular plan is with
verizon a t
t-mobile you're paying way too much for
the exact same coverage you could be
getting
right now with pure puretalk usa take a
look at your cell phone bill where it
shows data usage the average person who
switches to pure talk is using less than
four gigs of data a month the big
carriers are charging you for unlimited
data which is like paying for an entire
row on an airplane but only needing
one seat well pure talk will save the
average person over 400 bucks a year on
their wireless service with unlimited
talk and text and two gigs of data all
for just 20 bucks a month and if you go
over on data usage they're not going to
charge you for it so exactly what you
have to lose
folks switching to peer talk it's very
very easy and it's going to save you a
bundle grab your mobile phone
dial pound 250 and say my name ben
shapiro when you do you say 50
off your very first month dial pound 2 5
0 say keyword ben shapiro pure talk is
simply smarter wireless you're going to
save money
on your cell phone bill and frankly you
can use the money so why exactly would
you not go and do that so i'll pound 250
save ben shapiro once more dial pound
two five zero and say ben shapiro to get
started with pure talk usa you could be
saving
up to half of your money on your cell
phone bill okay so big news of the day
yesterday is that president trump
made his grand return to the white house
and it was a return
with style see this is the thing that
trump is best at he is best at the
imagery
he is best at the sort of reality tv of
the presidency
now is it always appropriate no uh is
sometimes it very very weird
sure but the guy definitely knows how to
do imagery we're gonna get to the
imagery
the pure imagistic magnificence
of the president disembarking from the
helicopter and going into the white
house yesterday
we'll get to that in a second but that
was actually not the first controversy
of the day yesterday if we were going to
recount controversies the first
controversy of the day is that trump
tweeted optimistically and you are
apparently
no longer allowed to do this so trump
tweeted out yesterday i will be leaving
the great walter reed medical center
today at 6 30 p.m
feeling really good don't be afraid of
covid don't let it dominate your life we
have developed under the trump
administration some really great drugs
and knowledge i feel better than i did
20 years ago well probably that has less
to do with with the covet than it has to
do with you know going like three full
days without the diet coke and
the hot wings but with that said when
trump says
don't be afraid of covet this is what
set people off so
he is correct that you shouldn't be
afraid to live your life the problem is
that there are a lot of people who kind
of should be afraid of covid i mean if
you are above the age of 70 then this
thing is pretty deadly if you're above
the age of 70
about five percent of people who acquire
the disease above the age of 70
could die from it which is a very high
number if you are 20 then you should not
be afraid of covet and he is right about
this
so the fear level that you have with
kovid has to be trenched by population
as we have been saying from the very
outset
this is why when you hear scientists say
things like we can't pursue hurt
immunity we have to stop pursuing hurt
immunity
okay if what you mean is we shouldn't
let the virus simply run roughshod
through the population and hit everybody
equally
that of course is true nobody wants to
see this wipe through nursing homes the
same way that it did the first time
around
if however you mean that we have to stop
everybody who is 20 from getting covered
that's incredibly silly
because if you're 20 and you get covered
you're you're going to be fine i mean by
and large you're going to be fine it
doesn't mean that a few people who are
under the age of 20 aren't going to die
some people will but the rate of death
from kovid
from obtain you obtain covid and you're
20 years old your rate of death is
something like
one in ten thousand maybe two in ten
thousand
okay in other words not the kind of risk
that you take into account when you go
about
your daily life and that's if you obtain
the thing not even if you're just
walking around as a 20 year old because
your chances of obtaining the thing is
20 year old are not 100
anyway so should you be walking around
afraid
probably not but but everybody gets very
angry at trump for saying
don't be afraid of the virus apparently
you're supposed to be afraid you're not
supposed to be
you know careful and cautious which of
course is perfectly appropriate
you're not supposed to take things
seriously which again is perfectly
appropriate you're supposed to live
in deep and abiding fear of the virus
you're supposed to walk around
each day with just an inane sense of
dread
that this virus is going to get get you
and it is going to come out of the
woodwork and it is going to kill you
and again the stats do not back this up
generally speaking
just like any other disease it will kill
some people this is not the bubonic
plague however and the death rates on
this thing
are not the rates of ebola so the
question
as to how much fear you should have on a
daily basis should be connected to the
data in some way shape or form for the
media however they have been
deliberately for months
hiding the data so that you don't
actually know your relative risk factor
is why polls have shown
that americans think that this thing is
like somewhere between 50 and 100 times
more deadly than it actually is meaning
if you ask the average american
out of a thousand people who who get
coveted how many are going to die
a lot of people are gonna tell you you
know maybe a hundred okay it's not even
close
even for the most vulnerable subgroups
of the population it's not close to that
particular number
so how much fear should you have depends
on your risk factors depends on your age
but should you be walking around in deep
fear every day as opposed to
you know with a certain amount of
caution of course not now that doesn't
mean
that trump himself exemplifies that
caution and herein lies the problem
let's say that all the way back in march
or april trump had done something
very very simple with the virus okay
just to promote just to look in on sort
of his messaging strategy
let's say that president trump had taken
a look at the virus and he said listen
these lockdowns suck
they are bad they are counterproductive
they do not do what they are supposed to
do
they suppress the virus for the moment
which is what they are supposed to do
but they do not crush the virus which is
what people are now saying right we
gotta crush the virus with lockdowns you
can't crush
the virus with lockdowns which is why
when the lockdowns are alleviated
literally everywhere this is tried there
is some level
of community spread so how exactly do
you quote unquote stop
the virus well either the virus is at
such low levels that you can actually
test
and trace and then you mandatorily
quarantine people the way that they were
doing in china or the way they were
doing in south korea
that is one strategy presumably the
other strategy is that you're going to
have to
let it run through particularly healthy
segments of the population at a low
level with social distancing
with masking taking precautions so you
don't overrun the hospital system
and then you move on with your life and
that's sort of what sweden has done
right there was some masking a little
bit not too much
there's a lot of social distancing in
sweden and they never shut down the
schools and they never shut down the
businesses and now community spread in
sweden is very very low well with its
neighbors it is significantly higher
so what if trump back in april said
listen lockdowns
they're not a good idea we shouldn't do
them but in order for you to get back to
work what you should do is you should
socially distance and you should mask up
when you're in a crowded area and then
we can all get back to work and we can
learn to live with the virus what if you
had said that
as opposed to this sort of back and
forth on whether masks are good or not
the sort of dismissive language with
regards to masks the the sort of
unwillingness to abide by
basic social distancing protocols if
trump had done all of those things
it wouldn't have left an opening for joe
biden which joe biden is running a truck
through
right now okay with that said the media
took the other side from trump because
no matter what trump does the media will
do the opposite one of the amazing
things that is happening right now in
the united states
is that you see how the left has gone
full pro lockdown well if you take a
look at israel by way of contrast
benjamin netanyahu the prime minister of
israel is a right-wing prime minister
right he's a lecoup prime minister
he has pursued full-scale lockdown the
people who are out in the streets
protesting right now
are the far leftists which shows you
just how reactionary politics is all the
way around the world
in america anti-lockdown is right wing
in israel
anti-lock down is left-wing there's some
religious parties who are also
anti-lockdown
in israel but it does show you that the
the sort of reactionary sides of the
political debate they tend to react to
whomever is in power as opposed to
reacting to the policy itself anyway
trump tweets don't be afraid and the
media immediately go no no we have to be
super duper afraid how could he say
don't be afraid we should all live in
fear we should live in abject fear of
this virus
okay no you should not live in object
fear of the virus again you should look
at your risk factors and then you should
take responsible action to protect
yourselves
and members of your family my risk
factors i'm 36
i have very very minimal risk factors
thank god i am healthy i am young
my parents risk factors are more
substantial they're in their
mid-60s and my dad takes statins
so for that that means that i take
precautions when i'm around my parents
again everyone can do this this is not
all that difficult but
nobody is willing to go to the halfway
point so trump says don't be afraid
which if you were also saying act
responsibly on a regular basis would be
no problem he'd be exactly right
instead he's sort of promoting this it's
not a big deal
meanwhile the left goes not only should
you be afraid you should be super afraid
you should spend your life
cowering in fear in fact you should be
living in your basement right now
peeing into jars like howard hughes so
here's the media's reaction
to trump simply saying don't be afraid
of the virus
almost 210 000 americans are
dead speaking of outrageous uh this
outrageous tweet
oh my goodness nicole when i saw that
trump
i mean i i literally was overwhelmed
and now we see this tweet which is
heartless it is uh
cruel jake this is this is so
disrespectful i'm not even sure i can i
can speak about this
it's incredibly uh incredibly
disrespectful what does that mean don't
be afraid of it
i mean first of all it's it's a
contagious disease that kills people
there's nowhere to even begin it's gross
okay that is such a wild overreaction
that is a wild and insane overreaction
to don't be afraid of covet don't let it
dominate your life
what he is not saying there is run
willy-nilly out into the streets and
start licking telephone poles
right go kiss somebody with kovat that's
not what he is saying
that's what half the democratic party
was saying in late february
but you know none of that matters at
this point nonetheless the media
wish to promote a sense of panic about
the virus and that is irresponsible
but that is the theme the theme is that
trump's messaging on this virus has not
been good it continued to not be
particularly good yesterday and the
media's overreaction to the virus
is not only not good it promotes really
bad public policy
so it's just a mess all the way around
nobody is responsible in their rhetoric
and it's really really irritating we'll
get to more of this in just one second
first i gotta tell you about this new
service that i've been trying
it is just fantastic i'm talking about
myphoto.com
so on your cell phone you have a bunch
of photos right you take a bunch of
photos of your kids and your family
every single day and then they just pile
up there and then one day you're like
you know what what should i do with all
these photos maybe i'll make like a
photo book
except that's going to take you a year
of your life you know it would be
amazing
if you had a service where you could
literally just take your favorite photos
send them in
and then within like a couple of days
you would get back a beautiful
a beautiful framed photo or a beautiful
a beautiful piece of metal glass wood
with your photo on it this is what
myphoto.com
does it is a fantastic company makes it
super easy makes
really convenient gift giving especially
come holiday season
so the other day for example i was
looking through my photo i was looking
through my
my photo album on my phone and i saw a
picture of me and my wife and my kids
and i immediately sent it to myphoto.com
and now i have this beautiful acrylic
cube
with the photo it's just beautiful i
mean the colors in it are glowing
it's incredible and it goes right on my
desk it is fantastic okay it took me
five seconds
that's how convenient it is and it
didn't cost me a fortune go check out
myphoto.com right now literally takes me
two minutes to do it
and then you get it in five days you
gotta try it right now go to myphoto.com
you can easily see your photo on all
their products
and then you can simply purchase you
like preview it and see what it actually
will look like use the code
bend25 at checkout for 25 off go to
myphoto.com right now
use the code ben25 you'll see how easy
and fun it is
it can actually be addicting it's pretty
fantastic you can stack your entire
house
with beautiful photos of your family
that would have been forgotten on your
phone for years until
like a year from now you'd look back and
say what did i ever do with that photo
the answer is nothing go to myphoto.com
and use the code ben25 to preserve that
photo for all time by the way i know the
founders of the company it is just a
like wonderful wonderful people people
that i trust personally so it's a great
company
with great founders and you're going to
love the products go check them out
right now at myphoto.com and use the
code bend25 at checkout for 25
off okay so that wasn't the only media
insanity of the day
trump's doctors announced that he'd be
heading back to the white house and the
media lost their mind yesterday now
be it noted that normally when you
quarantine you quarantine at home
okay so trump going back to the white
house and not being stuck at the
hospital
it is not the end of the world he
doesn't have to stay at the hospital
taking up hospital resources unless he
requires hospital resources
shipping him back home is pretty much
what you would be instructed to do
if you went in and you tested positive
for covid at the hospital
right now and you were not experiencing
life-threatening symptoms they would
send you home
and then you would isolate in your home
right that is what you are supposed to
be doing
so here are trump's doctors announcing
that yesterday and the media losing
their minds
over the prospect i mean i don't know
what they want here they just want trump
to be in the hospital forever i suppose
they would like trump to stay in the
hospital
until the end of this election cycle as
opposed to going back to the white house
they're insulted by the fact that trump
is even going back to the white house
here are the doctors announcing
that trump was headed back to the white
house yesterday
so long as everything continues on the
track that we're we're experiencing
right now
this time as the president already
tweeted out
is to get him home later today and if
he's still on that medication how is it
safe for him to return to the white
house so we sit
uh we send patients home with
medications all the time
how was it safe for him to drive around
in a cloth mask yesterday
and how is it safe for him now to return
to the white house where there have been
so many cases
how's any of this safe okay so the media
we're very very upset
that that it's it's deeply unsafe okay
first of all i promise you the secret
service they're wearing ppe
they're wearing n95s they're wearing
goggles apparently
in order to transport the president this
was true when he went on his little car
ride his
slightly ill-advised car ride over the
weekend
and the doctor said also that he may not
be out of the woods yet because you
never know what trajectory the disease
is going to take and this was taken
as evidenced by the media that it was
medically irresponsible to send him
back to the white house for him to
shelter in place again that is true of
everybody who's not currently
experiencing life-threatening symptoms
if you don't need
any sort of heavy machinery but by the
way the white house also happens to have
some medical facilities in the white
house so unless you need really
sophisticated medical equipment
it is trump is like the safest person in
the world sheltering in the house
in which he lives here's the doctor
announcing yesterday that he may not be
entirely out of the woods but we're at
least comfortable sending him home
it's been more than 72 hours since his
last fever
oxygen levels including ambulatory
saturations
and his work of breathing are all normal
though he may not entirely be out of the
woods yet the team and i agree that all
our evaluations
and most importantly his clinical status
support the president's safe return home
where he'll be surrounded by world-class
medical care 24
7. okay so that is correct that did not
stop the media from losing their minds
because again no matter what trump does
it is wrong for the media if he goes to
the hospital
that's wrong if he comes home from the
hospital that is wrong if he shelter's
in place
well then where is he is he safe and
then if he doesn't shelter in place then
he's endangering everybody that doesn't
mean that trump has been
responsible throughout this as we'll see
i don't think he has been
i mean i've been pretty clear about that
but the media have been
two things can be true at once trump can
be acting irresponsibly in many cases
and the media can absolutely suck at
their jobs so here was brian stelter
going absolutely wild yesterday
over trump even leaving the hospital
again it is perfectly appropriate for
him to leave the hospital when he is not
in life-threatening condition
so long as the people around him are
protected when he is in their presence
and then he goes back home and he
shelters melania right now has coveted
she's in the white house
and she's sheltering her place in the
white house here's brian steltzer on cnn
being a reliable source
it's not a real show of strength but
it's a performative
show of strength this is what strong men
do in autocratic regimes
of course thankfully we are in a
democracy but this is the kind of thing
you see in
uh from strongmen who want to appear to
be leading
it's a dear leader sort of approach and
i think that is what we are seeing on
our television screens
meanwhile there are big questions about
the cover-up you know why won't they
tell us about his testing history
when he was tested we've moved from this
possibly being a cover-up to
actually being a cover-up it's a
strongman routine you see
him going back home that is the strong
man routine now as we'll see
there is this habit that trump has which
is the media make a criticism of him
and the criticism is utterly
illegitimate and then within about 35
seconds trump does something you go well
maybe it's not
totally illegitimate it's really
irritating
right the media will say trump is not
taking masking seriously
and then trump will actually take
masking seriously you'll be like that's
unfair and then five seconds later
trump will be like oh a mass they're
stupid god why are you doing that
why why why like trump he specializes in
throwing gasoline on fires
he's just the gasoline on fire guy okay
so again the media went nuts yesterday
cnn's
sanjay gupta he said he should stay in
the hospital apparently forever sanjay
gupta
is now his personal physician knowing
all of the intricacies of his medical
condition
these are all the things that sort of
make it pretty obvious he should stay in
the hospital
and and not the least of which you know
this is a sort of illness that we know
people can sort of be doing okay for a
period of time i don't think this is a
medical decision we'll see what the
doctors say as caitlyn pointed out but
um
i think this is this is his decision and
this is you know basically him saying
i'm going to do this so
i don't think the doctors if you're just
looking at the data you're paying
attention to his risk factors
you're paying attention to how sick he
has been um
you would you would advocate for this at
all okay again
he has doctors who are treating him he
doesn't need sanchi gupta who
misdiagnosed
chris cuomo on air using a fuzzy cell
phone video of a lung scan
in order to tell trump whether he can or
cannot go to the hospital okay so
all of this is illegitimate at this
point right and at the point at this
point in the narrative yesterday this is
all illegitimate trump is allowed to go
back to the white house
as long as people around him are
shielded he's allowed to go back and he
is allowed to shelter
in the white house until he is done with
his 10-day course right that is the way
that this is supposed to work
okay then trump actually went back to
the white house and again the media
doubled down on how terrible it was that
he had headed back to
the white house so it was like okay
trump is not wrong the media is wrong
trump is not wrong the media's not wrong
then trump is like well that's not
so right what trump is doing we'll get
to that in just one second
everything is so stupid we'll get to
more of this in a second first let us
talk about the fact it is halloween this
month policy genius would like to mark
vacation by making something less scary
life insurance shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
policy genius will make it easy they
combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with help
from licensed experts to save you time
and money right now you could save 50 or
more by using policy genius to compare
life insurance when you're shopping for
a policy that could last for more than a
decade those savings really do start to
add up here's how it works well
first you head on over to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price policy genius will then
compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day you might even be eligible to skip
the in-person medical exam
and then once you apply the policy
genius team handles all the paperwork
and the red tape
best part they work for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything soup to
nuts so if you need life insurance head
on over to policygenius.com
right now to get started you could say
50 or more
by comparing quotes policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
important to get it right
if you are a human with dependence you
need to make sure that your family is
taken care of in case
god forbid something should happen to
you go check them out right now at
policygenius.com there's a reason they
have a five star rating
across over 1 600 reviews on trustpilot
and google you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes over at
policygenius.com check them out right
now
at policygenius.com okay so trump
finally returns to the white house does
all this lead up
he gets on the helicopter the media are
complaining how dare he leave the
hospital
how dare he again he has medical doctors
who say can leave the hospital but you
know who knows better
brian stelter and the anchors at sienna
okay finally trump returns
to the white house and cnn promptly goes
nuts
over him removing his mask so there were
two videos
originally that came out from cnn first
video was the one that people started to
go nuts over and again this was
this seemed to be unfair trump gets off
the helicopter he proceeds to walk up to
the balcony of the white house
and then he takes off his mask for the
photo op
and the media lose their minds over this
so here was trump yesterday
doing this again in this particular
video he happens to be
dozens of feet away from any other
living human being and he is outside
even if you have covet you do not need
to wear a mask under those conditions
okay where you wear a mask is where
you're afraid of transmitting it to
somebody else
if i were alone on a beach in the middle
of the wilderness and i had coveted i
mean hell if i had bubonic plague an
hour alone on the beach in the middle of
the wilderness i would not need to wear
a mask
that's stupid that was the first video
people were going nuts over here was
trump yesterday doing this
this is awesome here we go a very
different
takes it off an incorrect message and
you see him here
he takes it off and he's getting ready
for his pictures the flags flank him
right caitlyn this is what he did this
is the moment this is what he produced
it for he wants the image to be
what the president is portraying by
taking his mask off
when he gets back to the truman balcony
to give this
this grand return to the white house is
that everything is fine and as he said
don't let coronavirus control your life
but that is very much still a president
who has coronavirus
okay fine so chris cuomo of course went
completely nuts
on this he started ranting and raving
about how this is bs and how the virus
is reality
none of this is reality the virus is
real how dare trump
do a photo op how dare he do a photo op
over
kovad and uh and chris cuomo i just have
a question
here's chris cuomo first of all tonight
he had his video crew capture that
stupid scene again so he could put out
propaganda
fronting a lie to his people once again
just like
don't worry about the mass now he says
don't worry about kovac don't let it
control your life
just propaganda that's all it is
um i just have a question for chris
cuomo if you're going to say that it's
bs to do a photo op
after emerging from from covid i'm just
going to note that
you famously emerged from your basement
like a groundhog
in order to proclaim that you are now
covert free after infecting your entire
family and of course
traveling outside your home like there
are plenty of media members who have the
credibility i guess to say something
about this chris cuomo
is not one of them the media went nuts
over
those particular images right those
particular images drove them absolutely
batty
so for example cnn's aaron burnett she
suggested this was like
north korea now north korea is where you
take your brother-in-law you strap him
to an anti-aircraft gun and then you
blow him away
north korea is where you take your
distant relatives who may or may not
be a threat to your rule and then you
poison them in an airport
i'm sorry the the president going up
onto a balcony and taking a picture that
is not like north korea
if we were just talking about you know
staged photo ops barack obama did a fair
number of them that is not like north
korea either it can be self-aggrandizing
it can be egotistical it can be stupid
it can be arrogant it is not like north
korea here's aaron burnett comparing
things that are not like north korea to
things that are like north korea
what we're seeing here really looks like
it's like something out of north korea
the dear leader comes out right with the
with the
the magnificent helicopter entrance and
and up the stairs and and off goes the
mask as he pauses you know
and preens for the for the shots
yeah i was half expecting him to to uh
hold up a bible at the end of that shot
oh my god this is your objective media
journalism and all the
the journalism is getting everywhere
guys and it's hot and sticky it's just
everywhere
really really gross really gross
journalism joy reid who's a wonderful
journalist
in her own right she said she was
absolutely disgusted by this display i'm
just gonna note that this entire media
was totally fine with people burning
cities five seconds ago like
burning them down right people murdering
people on the streets that was totally
cool because that was all for racial
justice
but trump got off a helicopter and stood
on a balcony and took off a mask
when he was dozens of feet from other
people they say here is joy reid being
very very disgusted with all of this
i am speechless i am stunned i have to
be honest with you i'm disgusted
by what i just saw this man is
contagious
he just exposed his secret service
agents who as nicole wallace pointed out
are some of the finest
most professional people anyone who's
ever experienced the secret service
knows they are true professionals in
every moment of their job
would take a bullet for this president
not take one from the president
okay so you know it was terrible how
could he go back jim acosta
was costing as well he said this could
be patient zero returning to the white
house
because of course trump is suspected of
perhaps infecting people who are around
him so this is patient zero returning
that's where he lives guys i mean he's
the president of the united states i
know you can't deal with that fact
but that is where he lives so here is
jim acosta being jim acosta
keep in mind this is not just the
president returning to the white house
this may be patient zero
this is the virus coming back to the
white house and i will tell you wolf
having been here all day
it is eerily quiet and empty
inside the corridors of the west wing uh
with kaylee mcandy the white house press
secretary testing positive for the virus
to press assistance
testing positive of the virus they
evacuated much of the west wing
earlier today all of those staffers have
gone home just about all of those
staffers have gone home so
uh forget about the emperor has no
clothes uh the emperor has no staff
tonight
okay he's just the worst i'm sorry of
course kaylee mcinney went home she
tested positive what do you think she's
gonna hang around in the hallways
i know white house employees who are on
the job and staying away from trump
because trump is still contagious okay
so all this seems really unfair you're
like why is the media doing this routine
he's just literally going back to the
white house and then the initial photos
were of him
getting off the helicopter and then
walking up the stairs and then taking
off the mask when no one else
was around okay that was the initial
tape
and then trump does what trump does
which is he proceeds to
go too far and then it just all
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact
that as we grow closer to this
contentious election
end right we are now only three weeks
away from the end of this election cycle
you need a great pair of premium
wireless earbuds you're into the news
you are you are consuming it with daily
furvid fervor this is why you need a
great pair of wireless earbuds but not
the super expensive ones that are like
one size fits all
they don't fit your ear all that great
you instead need wireless earbuds from
raycon
raycon's newest model the everyday e25
earbuds those are the best ones yet
six hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass a more compact design
a noise isolating fit
raycon earbuds are stylish and discrete
no dangling wires no stems
give them a try raycon has a 45 day free
return policy so you can be sure that
they are the pair of wireless earbuds
for you
i love my raycon specifically because
they have a variety of fits so they fit
perfectly in my ear for a limited time
get 15
off your order at buy raycon dot com
slash ben that is b
u y r ay c ben for a special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds make
sure to check it out now while the deal
is running
buy raycon.com ben get 15 off your order
by going to buyreicon.com
ben okay so the media they're they're
overreacting to all of this trump said
don't be afraid and they took it as
he's saying you should willy-nilly just
go out there and obtain covet yourself
trump decides to go back to the white
house that is the end of the world when
he left the white house in
the first place that was the end
everything is the end of the world then
trump proceeds to do something that
apparently is incredibly unwise
he goes up onto the balcony and he takes
off the mask and then
what the video shows is that he is in
close consultation
with other people apparently not wearing
the mask and he does this in full public
view
so it becomes pretty clear later that
what he was doing was he was shooting a
video
in which he is back shadowed by the by
the washington monument
we'll shut we'll see that video in just
one second but you can see in this video
that he is in very close consultation
with other people again he is contagious
he does have covet he's around a bunch
of other people including apparently
cameramen
that's not responsible that is not
responsible okay if you know that you
have covid
it is morally wrong to be inside a
particular radius with other people
without wearing a mask so that you are
less likely to transmit covid to them
okay by the way it is no less wrong to
go and do that with the flu
okay like if you are if you have a
transmissible disease and you get within
a certain distance of people
and you can transmit it to them you need
to be at the very least wearing a mask
you should be protecting them
okay so trump does that and now you have
entered the territory where the media's
criticisms
start to look a little bit less crazy it
looked like they were going absolutely
nuts over nothing yesterday
and then trump does that and you see the
video of it and you're like okay well
why would you do that why and i
understand from a lot of trump fans well
he's trolling them he's trolling him
well guess what
the trolling is not particularly useful
all the time it turns out that when you
keep trolling and you keep trolling and
you keep trolling sometimes people get
annoyed and i'm not talking about
members of the media
i'm talking about like the general
american public i think that right now
what you are watching in the poll
is in the polls right now and it's still
early maybe there's time to make it up
but right now you're watching an
enormous break for joe biden in the
polls
there's a poll out today biden plus 16.
there's a poll out yesterday biden plus
14.
i know there are people who are now in
the business of unskewing the polls i'm
not in the business of unskewing the
polls i'll tell you why in 2012
many of us on the right spent days and
days going through the interior poll
statistics to try and quote unquote
unskew the polls
what we came up with was that romney was
going to win it was a much closer
election than this one
right now the polls are not close in the
real clear politics national polling
average donald trump is down nearly 10
points
in various states it is significantly
closer but in arizona the latest poll
has him down eight
in florida the latest polls have him
down somewhere between three and five
he is now he's now trailing by a slight
margin in places like north carolina
those are not the kind of numbers he
needs in order to win re-election
so put aside the the immorality of
standing close to people when you know
you have kovid
wearing no mask put that aside is it
smart politics to do any of this
it is not in fact smart politics to do
any of this and in fact you know i
i gotta say you know as somebody who
maybe i take covet a little more
seriously than than
other people my age maybe i take covert
a little bit more seriously than other
people
with my job but the the reality is that
i take covet a little bit more seriously
because i think that it's actually
fairly serious
i don't think that it's again bubonic
plague i don't think that the vast
majority of people are going to die from
it i'm the only person
in the media i believe who's been
spending a lot of time on a day-by-day
basis talking to actual doctors
literally on a day-by-day basis on my
show trying to sell you
actual statistical data from various
countries and from around the world i've
tried to be as accurate as possible in
conveying that information
trump's rhetoric on this stuff has not
been good and it is coming back to bite
him directly in the butt
okay so trump cuts this video yesterday
and he
frankly he looks pretty good in the
video right he says
he he's standing outside the uh there he
actually there were three videos that
came forth from the
trump campaign video number one he
talked about perhaps
he was immune okay so he's talking about
how he's had kovid
he reiterates you shouldn't be afraid of
it again i think that
the answer is you shouldn't live your
life in complete fear again i generally
agree
with this message right that you
shouldn't live in fear of it
yeah and he does look pretty good right
i mean he's standing flanked by two
american flags you can see behind him
the washington monument this apparently
is the little video that he was taking
when he was in fairly close contact with
other people here was trump talking
about his experiences with covid
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your lives
don't let that happen we have the
greatest country in the world
we're going back we're going back to
work we're going to be out front
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
i stood out front i led nobody that's a
leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
and now i'm better and maybe i'm immune
i don't know
okay so number one he is not yet immune
he is still in the throes
of the virus one of the things that's
happened i i have i know people who
literally died of the virus who started
off it looked okay
it looked a little worse it looks a
little better and then i got a lot worse
so we're not quite out of the woods yet
i mean his own doctors say we're not out
of the woods
trump's original message there which is
you know don't
live in complete abject fear of the
virus is the correct message we don't
need to lock down again
like this is where the president's
rhetoric connects to public policy
we don't need to lock down again we
shouldn't live in abject fear of the
virus right again that original tweet
don't be afraid was not the end of the
world in fact i think that the tweet was
actually not bad
it is the last part of what he says
where you start to go come on right when
trump says things like
as your leader i had to go i had to i
had to lead what
are you not suggesting that as the
leader of the free world as the
president of the united states you had
to get covered
is that the suggestion here is that in
order to show people that covet is
livable that you had to get covered that
you knew you were going to survive
so i have general moral objections to
treating quote unquote defeating a
disease as some sort of active willpower
i don't think that's actually how
disease works
i hate it when people discuss cancer in
these terms right you'll see people and
they get cancer
and then if they god forbid die of
cancer you'll see people say well they
lost their battle with cancer they
didn't lose
their battle with cancer okay it's not
like if they had a better strategy they
win
or if they'd only had more willpower to
push over that final hill then they
would have defeated cancer
everybody enjoys living to the extent
that they have not committed suicide
what that means
is that you are not quote unquote
defeated by the disease
the disease may defeat your health
system but it has not defeated you
because i do not identify you
with your immune system nor is it an act
of willpower to defeat covet it's not as
though you're morally superior should
you beat covet and you're morally
inferior if you die of covet i hate this
sort of language
this idea that trump went out there and
he was like you know i had to be brave
so i wear no mask and i went in front of
other people and we hung out together
because
i'm a leader like it is not
non-leadership to be cautious
now again i agree that there is a
moderate halfway point between
willy-nilly doing whatever the hell you
want and being joe biden and hiding in
your basement the rest of your life
and you know i get it joe biden's 78
years old he doesn't want to get covered
because again he is in the high risk
category
but there is a halfway point and the
halfway point is the social distancing
it is the mask wearing and biden more
and more has been getting out and
actually doing some of that mask wearing
and you're seeing him start to message
this okay this is why when trump does
this sort of triumphal procession
back to the white house here's what his
attitude should have been after
he got healthy from covet thank god for
my doctors my doctors were excellent
thank god for the medication that we
have developed the therapeutics we have
developed it shows that many of the
policies we have been pursuing
are the correct and right policies now
that i have coveted i can tell you it's
a serious i mean it's on oxygen twice
right
you can say i i can tell you that it was
it was very unpleasant
it was serious we have a great medical
system in this country
it is important to socially distance and
mask up if we don't want to see that
medical system
overwhelmed if you are in a vulnerable
population you should do
all of those things and we can get back
to work
instead because trump is trump he
decided to treat
his emergence from covid as some sort of
great moral victory for himself
so he put out this video yesterday and i
mean frankly like
the video itself if you saw this context
free you'd have literally no idea
what the video is celebrating so the
video shows marine one
landing on the lawn over at the white
house and listen i know this is an
unpopular view
on my side of the political aisle i get
it but tough
okay so here's marine one landing on the
lawn
so marine one comes and it lands on the
lawn of the triumphal music right to the
triumphal
movie music and then you're gonna see
the president of the united states get
out of marine one
and he gets that glory shot where he
stands up on the balcony and he salutes
again none of this is like morally wrong
in the way that the media are suggesting
ah
it's terrible and awful and no good and
very bad but
it is strategically obtuse okay here's
here's a bit of the video
as marine one landing on the lawn at the
white house in slow motion
the wheels come down the door opens his
secret service agents come off wearing
masks he comes off wearing a mask
and there he is walking on the lawn like
a hero
okay and then he goes up to the balcony
and
and off comes the mask and he salutes
marine one as the marine one flies away
okay so um i'm just gonna note right
here
first of all i want this sort of
treatment every time i successfully
complete a grocery list that my wife has
assigned to me at the grocery store i've
yet to successfully complete one of
these grocery lists i always forget one
thing
in fact before i go to the grocery store
i ask my wife which thing would you
prefer i forget because i will forget
at least one thing so you need to tell
me which one you want me to forget but
you don't get i'm sorry you do not get a
triumphant return video with like
dramatic movie music for not dying
like this is how low our bar is in
american politics trump doesn't die so
he gets a triumphant
uh triumphant video and all joe biden
has to do to be president apparently at
this point is not be a dead human like
actually not be dead
so both of our candidates right now
their campaign is i'm not dead
which i gotta tell you like not the most
inspiring campaign slogan
i survived covet and all i got was the
stupid white house is not like the most
inspiring
is not the most inspired i held out in
the basement and what i got is this
stupid white no
so now we've got captain i hide in
basement and captain i survived kovid
and like
i'm sorry what does any of this have to
do with bettering the lives of the
american people
why exactly am i supposed to be like i'm
super happy that trump recovered
okay i and anybody of good heart should
be very happy when the president of the
united states recovers from a deadly
disease and god willing he should be
healthy
going forward obviously i don't
understand
like just in general treatment of
disease i don't understand why we as a
society
treat it as some sort of active will to
defeat a disease to the point where you
deserve
a sort of like self-glorifying video
about how you fought the disease and you
defeat and it wasn't just that right the
trump
campaign released a video and i
understand it's supposed to be funny i
get it
okay and it is i mean it's like on a raw
level it's funny i guess
they released a triumphant video of
trump
literally tackling a like
beating the hell out of a he he's it's
trump as football player running
roughshod over
another football player with covet as
the head it's just
on twitter and it's unbelievably stupid
but like imagine
that you are somebody who's had a family
member or you know somebody who's
actually suffered with covet
and and didn't emerge is it because they
weren't as tough as trump
is that the theme here right here is
trump as a 49ers football player
it's trump's head and he's running down
the sideline and kova tries to tackle
him he just brushes cove it off because
he's just that tough
oh he just leaps right over kova look at
that and scores a touchdown there's
president trump
and then doing a funny dance and then
the uh and then the inevitable cut of
the
crazy lady from 2016 screaming into the
air
and then trump pence make america great
again that came from the trump campaign
that came from the trump campaign so let
me just say a couple of things one
on a raw level again hilarious who's the
uh who is the crowd for this
like i understand it's funny to me too i
get it it's funny but
is the trollery worth it because right
now that dude needs to make up
16 points in the polls like at this
point
he's he's got a little bit of ground to
make up particularly among everyone
you're not particularly among like one
group particularly among all the humans
like right now by issue again
i understand i'm telling you things you
don't want to hear but guess what
guess what if you want trump to win he's
going to need to turn a corner we are
running out of time here
okay it is october 6th the election
happens in less than one month we are 28
days to the election
and in two national polls he is losing
by 14
to 16 points those are not the numbers
you show me a polling outfit that gets
an election that wrong i don't mean
three to five points wrong like they did
in the states
i mean nationally 14 to 16 points wrong
20 points wrong and i will show you a
place that literally
cannot be in business next time around
we'll get to more of this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that a lot of businesses
unfortunately have gone under
during this time of covid crisis we've
been very fortunate here at daily wire
not only because of you not only because
of our constituents who have helped and
pitched in
and really joined the team but also
because we have excellent leadership
here my business partner jeremy boring
for as much as we make
fun of him and his wispy his wispy
facial hair
jeremy has done an excellent job leading
the company and that is why you know if
you're looking for some business tips i
would go to jeremy
in fact we're doing a sunday special
coming up with jeremy but you don't need
to wait for that instead you could take
advantage of a discounted ticket to
expert ownership live it's a virtual
conference october 21st and 22nd
featuring world renown leaders like john
maxwell the founders of duck commander
and otterbox
the benham brothers and of course
daleyware god king jeremy boring
this two-day virtual conference will set
you up with the skills you need to lead
through a crisis
you'll hear stories about the challenges
of startup journeys and the tough times
that come with any company
how these individuals push through
failure to come out successful on the
other side it's a great lineup we'd love
to have you join today for only 97 bucks
go to expertownershiplive.com before
midnight to register
for 97 bucks with an opportunity to buy
a second ticket for a friend
50 off come on you don't want to miss
jeremy do it for jeremy
again that's expert ownership live dot
com slash ben for 97 bucks today go
right now to expert ownership live dot
com
slash men to secure your spot okay we
are going to get to the polling numbers
and the fact that joe biden because of
trump's behavior because trump
needs to be front and center all the
time joe biden has been able to
completely escape all scrutiny
all scrutiny we'll get to that in just
one second first
in case you missed it we had another
great episode of the sunday special this
weekend academy award-winning actor john
voigt
joined me to discuss his illustrious
acting career his journey to
conservatism head on over to daily wire
apple podcast spotify or wherever else
you get your podcast to go check that
out right now and in case you didn't get
enough politics last week this wednesday
october 7th will be the vice
presidential debate between mike pence
and kamala harris
daly where's matt walsh will be the one
we forced to suffer
he'll be live reacting to the debate as
part of a special edition of all access
live
members can join that wednesday night at
8 30 p.m eastern 5 30 pm pacific at
dailywire.com to live chat with him on
the live stream and in the comments
if you're not a part of daily wire
already join now as an all access member
get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all of our upcoming debate coverage live
at dailywire.com
apple tv or the roku and join us on all
access live every single night for live
stream discussions
you also get not one but two leftist
years tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products that's
this wednesday october 7th 8 30 pm
eastern 5 30 pm pacific
join us get 20 off your all-access
membership with code debate
when you sign up today you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so joe biden has been able to completely
skate because of trump's behavior
because trump is the center of attention
because everything that he does has to
be big and glorious and macho because
it's hector camacho macho camacho
because he basically went out to the
balcony and decided to fire machine guns
in the air over defeating govit
he's been able to completely monopolize
the attention now
i understand normally in a presidential
race if you monopolize attention
then you win but that's because you're
usually spending that time attacking
your opponent and characterizing your
opponent
well joe biden has completely avoided
any and all scrutiny in fact he's made
his entire campaign
at least i'm not that guy and he's
especially doing that with regard to
masks he put out literally a three
second video
on his twitter feed and it was just a
graphic of trump taking off his mask and
joe biden keeping his mask on and that
was the entire thing
now again i agree with trump that very
often what you see from democrats what
you see from joe biden
is mask signaling you see people who are
in the middle of nowhere
wearing masks right they're out running
they're out jogging they're not near
anybody
and they're wearing masks in the middle
of the heat and you're like what are you
doing and then people yelling at you if
you don't wear a mask if you're out in
the middle of the heat
okay like all of that is incredibly
silly but the generalized message
it would only work if people had the
perception that trump was not being
responsible and right now
here is what the polls say okay you
don't have to like the data but the data
are the data
and i i understand we can completely
dismiss all of the data we can pretend
that the data don't exist or that it
doesn't matter we can hope against hope
that the data is wrong
this time but i just don't know why you
would
why you would stake your hopes on this
when you could theoretically do things
to alleviate the polling gap that exists
right now the real clear politics
national average has joe biden
up 9.2 points 9.2
by way of contrast hillary clinton was
up 4 at this point in the national
polling data
in the battleground states biden is
currently leading
in florida by 2.3 in pennsylvania by 6.6
in michigan by 5.8 in wisconsin by 6.0
okay all three of the battleground
states in the midwest
those are all outside the margin of
error in north carolina biden is now
leading by 1.2 in arizona
he is now leading by 3.4 including a
late-breaking poll in which he is
leading by eight
okay these are not the kinds of numbers
that donald trump requires
obviously quite obviously in fact
and so why exactly would we be sanguine
about that if you want to see biden
defeated
as i do why would you be sanguine about
any of this
likely voters according to a new cnn
poll broadly prefer biden over trump on
a number of issues
59 prefer 59 prefer biden on covid over
for trump on health care 59 to 39 39 on
racial inequality
62 to 36 on crime and safety
55 to 43 which is insane how in the
world is trump losing to joe
antifa biden 55 to 43 and i call them
antifa biden because
the guy literally refused to condemn
antifa from the stage he called it an
ideology or a philosophy
not a not a movement or an organization
52 percent of americans now say they
have a positive view of biden that is
not because they have a positive view of
biden that's because they have a
negative view of trump
opinions on biden haven't shifted one
iota it's just that people look at
candidates in comparison to one another
only 39
of americans have a positive view of
trump likely voters consider biden
more unifying 61-33 more honest and
trustworthy 58-33
they say that he cares more about people
like you 58-38 they say he has a clear
plan to solve the nation's problems
55-39
these stats are awful biden has expanded
his edge over trump among women
57 to 37 among people of color biden's
advantage is now 59
it's now i'm sorry 69 to 27 so he has
picked up 10 points
since september among white men without
college degrees
trump's support has actually increased
from 61 percent to 67 percent
but among all other groups he is down
and he is down heavily in fact among
white voters overall he is now trailing
he is now down four percent among all
white voters
so bottom line here is that if you take
seriously any of the stats
then you would think that trump has some
ground to make up and here's the thing
he could make it up if he allowed joe
biden to be the center of attention
all joe biden has been doing his entire
campaign right now again because he's
the anti-trump all he's doing is just
pointing
at trump and saying he's botching kovid
and then as we go into the fall and the
numbers start to uptick in certain areas
he has been downplaying any success that
we're seeing from the virus
now here's the thing if tr there was
such an open lane for trump here on
covet such an open lane and i said it in
real time so this is not 2020 hindsight
i said it at the time
all trump had to do was say no lockdowns
be responsible
no lockdowns be responsible that's it
if you just said that over and over no
lockdowns and be responsible
it would have been totally okay and not
only that
if he'd had no lockdowns and be
irresponsible means no mass gatherings
no huge mass gatherings then when
democrats decided randomly it was okay
for millions of people to go in the
streets and shout and spit on each
other about george floyd all he would
have had to do is say listen
you guys now own this you proclaim that
it's totally fine to do all of this in
the name of racial justice okay well
whatever spike happens that's now on you
because it is worthy of note that while
people suggested that those rallies did
not actually increase covert rates
the data suggests that the rallies
actually increased coveted rates
shockingly
shockingly who could believe it okay
biden however is uh is now going to
basically stake his entire campaign
on the pandemic not being over and also
on how much he loves masks that's now
the entire campaign and i understand
that that creates a reactionary need on
the right to say the masks are entirely
bad
they're not entirely bad the evidence on
masks is mixed
when you're in close contact with other
people you should be wearing
a mask okay when you're on an airplane
as i recently was you should be wearing
a mask
by the way biden is now proposing
policies that are already in place
that's how stupid we are okay we're like
biden's gonna fix all the problems
biden isn't fixing a damn thing the
airlines have had policies in place
right now that require you to wear a
mask if you are above the age of two
i was on a plane yesterday with my
children my children were wearing masks
except for the little tiny baby
anyway here was joe biden saying the
pandemic is far from over yesterday
he did this event in miami
since the president of the hospital on
friday
more than 100 since friday
more than 100 000 more people have been
diagnosed with covin
and this week at least five thousand
more
will die cases and deaths are climbing
in many states
i hope the president's recovery is swift
and successful but our nation's coveted
crisis
is far far from over okay so again
this is going to be his campaign and
then he suggests we should impose a mass
mandate on interstate travel
okay well first of all if you are
talking about like airlines
they already do i was just on a plane
yesterday they do they will throw you
off the plane and by the way
for po for folks who tried to resist the
airlines if you do that they will
they'll put you on the federal watch
list you won't be able to fly anymore so
just know that going in
but here was joe biden doing that
routine yesterday
i was glad to see the president speaking
and recording videos over the weekend
now that he's busy tweeting campaign
messages i would ask him to do this
listen to the scientists support
mass support a
mass mandates nationwide require a mask
in every federal building and facility
and interstate travel urge every
governor america to do the same we know
it saves lives
okay so again this is what his campaign
has been able to boil down to and and
part of that is that he's been very on
message and he's been able to hide in
the basement
and part of that's trump's fault i'm
sorry it is because guess what he could
have prosecuted a case against biden
i've been saying
since the riots he needs to say that joe
biden
has been standing aside and letting it
happen and joe biden in that debate i
know that we're completely ignoring what
biden said during the debate
in that debate joe biden refused to
contact antifa he refused
to say anything whatsoever about serious
racial violence in the cities except for
blaming white supremacists oddly enough
for the violence that has been plaguing
the united states
joe biden is a disaster area so when he
was asked why don't you call up some of
the heads of major cities and say crack
down on crime he said well i'm just
i'm just a retiree i'm just an older
retired gentleman
really are you or are you the head of
the democratic party as you said
he's been able to get away with all of
this he's been able to get away with
gaff after gaff after gaff because all
the focus
is on trump hey over the last
24 hours bernie sanders again
underscored the fact that bernie sanders
says he will be literally the most
progressive president ever
ever okay nobody's looking at joe
biden's agenda because nobody is looking
at joe biden period
and that is because of trump's
pathological need to be the center of
attention which has been a mistake since
the beginning
i've said it one million times on this
show if you wish to lose this election
make it a referendum on trump if you
wish to win this election make it a
referendum on biden
trump has spent zero time at making this
election a referendum on biden it's been
all about trump from beginning to end
and gotta say that's on trump
it really is here here's bernie sanders
doing uh
you know telling the the sad truth about
exactly who joe biden is
it is no secret no great secret at all
that joe biden and i
have differences of opinion but i also
want to tell you
that in fairness joe
if his campaign proposals
were to be implemented
they would significantly improve the
lives
of tens of millions of working families
and would make joe biden the most
progressive president
of the united states since franklin
delano roosevelt okay the how is that
not the campaign
how is that not the campaign but it's
not the campaign right it's not
joe biden is able to get away with
anything because again there's a bigger
shining headline right here
joe biden yesterday in the middle of an
event suggested that he's been able to
stay in his basement because black women
keep the shelves stocked imagine if
trump said this for half a second
and recognize just how racist it sounds
here was joe biden saying
something that certainly if any
republican had said it would be
considered the end of the world
because the american public the blinders
have been taken off
they've all of a sudden seen a hell of a
lot clearer
you see geez the reason i was able to
stay
sequestered in my home is because some
black woman was able to stack the
grocery shelf
yeah well why are the black women
stacking the grocery shelves joe
just that old daughtering fool
is leading donald trump by double digits
right now
that guy who's a horrible vice president
a horrible senator
a man who in open debate i mean he did a
town hall yesterday and he proclaimed
that he as vp had dealt with cuba and
russia
okay he as vp as part of an
administration
made it nice made lovey-dovey with raul
castro
and gave vladimir putin complete control
over crimea as well as syria
that guy is able to get away with it
because everybody's distracted by the
shiny object and the shiny object wants
to be the distraction that is
unconscionable politically
okay meanwhile meanwhile we are prepping
this week for a for a vice presidential
debate now
one of the strategies that i had
recommended all along it's very
frustrating
when um when you recommend a particular
strategy and it is then ignored
and then the and then the electoral gap
begins to open wide
i mean really open wide okay i suggested
as soon as kamala harris was made
the vice presidential candidate by joe
biden that she should be the issue
now imagine for just a second if donald
trump had done that imagine if he hadn't
made the issue donald trump
imagine if not every news cycle we're
about to imagine if he just receded to
his basement
and watched a shark week and said to joe
biden in that debate
not just talked over him for an hour and
a half
or had this sort of grumpy old man
walter matthau jack lemon fish fight
on the ice imagine if instead donald
trump had said
okay you know what joe what you say here
your assurances
first of all your assurances mean
nothing because you won't condemn antifa
because you refuse to condemn
black lives matter violence because you
took sides you literally took sides with
an alleged rapist in kenosha wisconsin
as opposed to siding with the police he
said the police should be arrested
and the alleged rapist required a phone
call of sympathy from you
that's the case of jacob blake instead
of doing that
instead of saying you know joe your
opinion frankly i don't think it matters
that much because the american people
know that you're probably not going to
fill out
two terms and maybe not even one term
right instead we should be focused on
kamal harris you know kamala harris has
not done a single press conference
she has not done one press conference
this entire time
she was nominated vice president by joe
biden in july
in july right at the very end of july it
was clear what was gonna happen was it
early august might have been early
august late july early august
she was nominated it is now october
she has not done a single press
conference she's done a couple of
interviews where she's avoided questions
studiously
like the plague like she's been as good
at avoiding questions as joe biden has
been at avoiding covet
and she's been able to avoid all of that
how has she not been the issue she is
one of the most radical senators in the
united states senate
she is his hand-chosen successor he
picked her
he may not like her but he picked her he
is not in great shape he's 78 years old
he is doddering he is stumbling over
himself so theoretically
if donald trump had put the focus on
kamal harris the pence harris debate
might actually matter a little bit
because it should matter because by the
way pence harris is significantly more
representative
of the ideological gap in this country
than trump biden
or trump is a non-ideological figure and
people hate him for non-ideological
reasons people don't hate trump because
he's a conservative
i mean they they do right trump weren't
conservative they wouldn't hate him the
same way but the things about trump that
they hate
are not the things about his
conservatism what they hate about trump
is not even his policy
because he's a conservative they hate
him but the things that if you ask
anybody on the left why they hate trump
they will never talk about his policies
they'll talk about him personally the
gap between
mike pence who's kind of traditional
republican and kamala harris who is the
mainstream of the democratic party is
much much more indicative of the
political differences between right and
left in this country
than any of the kind of personality
battles between slow old joe
and donald trump so this vp debate would
matter an awful lot
and right now here's what's amazing
despite how unpopular trump is and the
numbers show he's very unpopular with
the american people
right now mike pence is running dead
even with kamala harris
in the polls okay if they if they were
just talking about popularity
if it were just harris versus pence head
to head
a little less than half of likely voters
48 said they would vote for harrison a
head head-to-head with pence
45 said they would opt for pens okay and
that is
pence in the middle of an incredibly
unpopular administration by polling data
so imagine if trump if pence were not
part of a trump administration
imagine if this election for a second
just you know imagine for a second this
election were between mike pence and
kamala harris
i think pence wins that election by the
way if if this
election were between trump and harris
and trump had the
here's the problem if trump had the
capacity to get out of his own way he
would even win this election against
biden
but he can't get out of his own way so
normally this would be an
excellent time for people to focus in on
the vp debate
because there's a high likelihood that
kamala harris will be the 47th president
of the united states if joe biden
becomes the 46th
high high probability and i don't mean
when she wins an election
i mean when he god forbid something
happens to him
again he's 78 years old so this would be
a time when
her her campaign would be extremely
extremely
relevant and here's the thing pence
knows that and by the way pence is going
to skunk her in the debate here's my
prediction
my prediction is that wednesday night
pence is absolutely going to wreck her
she's going to try and separate him off
from trump she's going to go after trump
and pence is going to be a good soldier
and he's going to defend a lot of the
kind of indefensible things that trump
does on a personal level but when it
comes to policy she's gotten nothing
also kamala harris happens to be a not
very good debater i know that the media
are building her up to be this excellent
wonderful debater she is not a good
debater
the reason i know she's not a good
debater is because she had one good
debate with joe biden
in which she levered an acc she levied
an accusation at joe biden
and then she immediately provided zero
evidence to back it up and then fell
apart
on the stage and then tulsi gabbard took
her apart tulsi gabbard
so i think the mike pence will do the
same thing kamala harris is a lackluster
performer she's a lackluster performer
here was kamala harris over the last 24
hours
trying to imitate joe biden she's tried
to remake herself from radical democrat
medicare for
all racial justice to i'm just like joe
you know i'm like a moderate you know
we're fighting for the soul of our
broad general nonsense that she's never
asked a tough question
this campaign our campaign as joe
says is about fighting for the soul of
our nation
and when we talk about when joe talks
about fighting for the soul of our
nation
it's about fighting for working people
it's about fighting for families
it's about fighting for children it's
about fighting for health care
it's about fighting for good union jobs
it's about fighting to preserve our
climate and clean air
and clean water she's so bad at this
i mean she's so bad at this and mike
pence is going to actually push her on
these issues
remember that mike pence really wrecked
tim mccain in the last vice presidential
debate it's fun to watch the media try
to build her up as though she's really
good at this
she's so bad at this she dropped out of
the primaries before they even voted in
california
so that pence harris debate in a normal
election year
especially one where you have a 74 year
old and a 78 year old running against
each other
that would be a very relevant debate
unfortunately i wonder whether it'll be
relevant at all
to the polling data i wish it were
because i think that pence is
absolutely going to damage her in that
debate as well he should
okay well we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow in preparation for that vice
presidential debate i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam sciovets
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clayton
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton